[Music]
cody
is with us in houston texas hi cody how
are you
hey i'm good thank y'all for taking my
call sure what's up
i just needed some advice on how to
practice patience better whether it be
in my career or just life in general i'm
just
really impatient i've always been
peddled to the metal you know
climbed the ladder climbed the ladder
climbed the ladder and then coveted it
and stopped all the ladder climbing
so i'm just getting kind of bored where
i'm at and just needed to figure out how
to
be more patient with my life and career
progressions
what are you running from man
i don't know i just i grew up super
super super poor
and i'm tired of being that away i'm in
a lot better position now than i ever
dreamed of being i'm just
i'm just trying to not go back to that
place
when you say you're in a better position
what does that mean
uh just financially i mean me my wife we
live a you know we have a good life and
better than my family ever did growing
up so i don't know i'm just trying to
make sure i don't end up back there
when you say good life give me a picture
of that you talking about financially
your marriage is good you got
your kids are healthy what's that mean
we don't have kids but financially
our marriage is good i mean we're we're
in our second year of marriage now
so as good as two years of marriage can
be during a pandemic but
um i mean we make really good money i
mean we're both young we don't have any
kids
yet thankfully because they're expensive
but you know what's uh what's really
good money
uh between the two of us about 220 and
you're how old
she's 27 i'm 26. it's really good money
that's great money
so sometimes when folks
have a picture of a life they don't want
to have they take off
running as fast as they can another
direction and that's often a good thing
right but if your identity
doesn't become about building something
good but it becomes about
not being that then you're going to
always be running for the rest of your
life
and your identity will become as being a
sprinter
and so there's a way you could look at
this season you're making great money
great money astounding money in a city
that's not
super expensive and you can look at
slowing down as a curse or as
wow what a gift man i can spend more
time with my brand new wife
and we can figure each other out that
becomes
you're talking about legacy shift
earning the money
changing your financial footing that's
part of a legacy shift
but so is having great relationships
deep rooted trust with somebody you can
anchor and repel off the edge of
anything with or survive any car crash
with right
and so i'd love to challenge you
to come up with some practices that when
you start running from something
when your heart starts racing when you
get those looping thoughts in your head
i gotta go gotta go gotta go
that you and your wife come up with um
whether it's a code word or whether it's
a
a special meal or something that you
slow down and intentionally
practice being still there's one way to
practice patience brother and that's to
practice patience
i wish it was harder i wish it was more
complex than that it's not
um you have to decide that my life isn't
going to be judged on how many
zeros i have after my check they're
awesome
but it's not all of your life you're
gonna have to decide
that i'm gonna put prioritize some
things in addition to
changing my financial future right and
so
you're gonna have to decide to not spend
your life as a sprinter
the tortoise always wins always
there is something to be said man you
shot out of the gate and that's
incredible man
what do you have an emergency fund you
guys got a home you all set up
yes sir we're in three b and four so
we're we're out of
two and we do have the emergency fund
set up
so now you got to do the hard work you
sprinted you gazelled out right yeah you
finished up the
intensity now you're going to go to the
intentional and that's hard man four
five and six it's a gear change
so um how long you've been making 220
uh not that long in the last maybe six
months she just finished pa school so
when she got out and got a job
kicked it up yeah so based on the math
of what you've told me
and you're all focused intensity and
your high level of motivation
i'm going to tell you that 20 years from
today when you're in your mid 40s
you're going to have between 5 and 15
million dollars
yeah that'd be sweet now
the difference in 5 million and 15
million
in terms of what it does for what you're
running from
is zero five million gets you
as far away from poverty as 15 million
gets you
the only difference is which room you
stay in on vacation
and which how many lobster tail you
order with that steak that's really the
only
and really with either one of those
numbers you could do as much of either
of those things as you want to do
there's only so much crap you're going
to be able to buy
and the difference in 5 million and 15
million is merely legacy stuff
it's merely stuff you can do with
generations it's
merely things you can do with generosity
but your actual
state of well-being the difference
between 5 million and 15 million is
almost nothing
the difference between 5 million and 15
million that you the price you would pay
psychologically emotionally spiritually
between now and then to have 15 instead
of 5
ain't worth it is my point so 5
five at five at twenty years from today
or
seven or ten at twenty twenty years from
today
running a marathon pace instead of a
sprinter's pace
is all i want for you
i don't want you to have 20 and there's
nothing left in your guts
and your kids don't know who you are or
they don't like talking to you
or you're on marriage number three
and i work i work with wealthy people
for 25 years man
and i am wealthy and so and
you know i get up on uh sunday morning
and go to dunkin donuts at six o'clock
in the morning and take the grand babies
donuts with sprinkles on them
and you know you can do that with 5
million you can do it with 50 million
you can do it with 500 million
um you know and it really and the
laughter of the kids is really not even
going to change the car you drive
in that between the difference between
in other words at a certain point
wealth only begets more wealth it does
not change the your situation
that's right it doesn't change it
doesn't change your setting right
there's only so much i mean when your
home becomes two percent of your net
worth
instead of eight percent of your net
worth it doesn't change anything right
yeah it's not a
it's not a thing when it's a hundred
percent of your net worth that's when
you you are feeling that one
right you are feeling that one but um
but but there at some point
your uh
your environment is no longer your
personal lifestyle your environment is
no longer affected
unless you're just kind of some kind of
freak who's just buying
you know stuff like you know whatever
bling or you're trying to just buy stuff
to impress people i mean
you can do all that but even then you
know you just got another yacht that you
have to work on
right and they break down and so if
you've ever been hiking in the woods and
you turn a corner
and there's a bear you
have a built-in your heart races when
you go in the woods whenever you hear
something rustling you immediately
you've got to train yourself over time
to not see a bear
everywhere it's a rare occasion i've
been in the woods a million times it
just doesn't happen that often it does
occasionally
but man when you've seen poverty when
you've seen pain in your family
it's just such a good i do and it's so
hard to get your head out of that
because man our brains take care of us
david it's an interesting way to ask it
what's that how do i learn to practice
patience well that's somebody that's got
some wisdom and he's starting to see it
right it's not you know but i don't
think it's patience i think it's
contentment that's it
how do i practice practice peace
something this year that uh godliness
with contentment is great gain
i'm working this year to reverse
engineer the fruits of the spirit
what does it look like where do i see
peace where do i see gentleness
and where can i trace that limb back
instead of trying to do it over
here i'm trying to walk it back i'm just
going to open a can of gentleness that's
exactly
that's not how it works right so where
do i see it and i love his question
because he's certainly searching for
hey we got that money and i'm still not
just falling asleep at 10 o'clock yeah
i'm still
watercolor early promoter how do i just
go to sleep and i want to tell you
you practice peace you practice
gentleness you practice forgiveness
and slowly your default setting falls
that way yeah
that's good but he's on it man because
he asked the question and that's a gift
because he's not blaming everybody for
his lack of sleep he's not chasing
pills he's not chasing anger he's saying
how do i practice patience and you
practice patience
but practice and patience there you go